welcome to the Sevilla I'm playing a
fifteen minute game against connubial
Kenobi from Germany can do blue
how would you translate that yeah
something like a little knot or
something not quite sure how to
translate it all right we have a
reuleaux pass as black and it's played
an early in Queen e2 this is some a side
line which is some fact quite
interesting why turn white um can play
that if he wants to get away from the
well-known lines hmm okay
I know that before we should be certain
as good here what I forgot though what
exactly do I play on a form I know that
if R is not a big issue here but why
exactly
Jim it's probably there should be seven
it takes behind a b5 he first needs to
exchange on a age and while I cannot
take on b5 anyway because of efore
hanging yeah I see through him
yeah it this is often a move that is
played after a for to put impression on
b5 but it looks really weird to me at
least them in connection with Queen only
- so 94 looks like very very natural
reply to that hmm okay let's let's let's
go for that and not think ages okay he
needs to take on deform simply no other
booth I also have a look at the b3
bishop so there's no one no option to to
move the Queen as I would simply take b3
and get the bishops and okay it just
needs to take takes T for a deform and
then aha maybe you can play e5 hmm yeah
maybe you can take and play e5 maybe I
should have spent a bit of time on that
if I've now is a bit tricky maybe if
five takes on c3 takes on f6 takes on d2
Bishop d2 gf6 yeah I will upon but this
position looks really ugly
I don't know yeah I should have spent a
bit a bit of time at least so what now
mmm uncomfortable so takes on c3 takes
on f6 yeah cannot take with the bishop
on f6 because of this bloody pin so
takes on c3 take some f6 takes on D to
check Pacific Bishop d2 g f6 and then
something like Bishop h6 and then will
never get my King into any any kind of
safe position
okay what about canceling here if he
takes bishop takes the knight hangs and
I'm threatening rupee eight hmm so
probably I'll get my get the piece back
night before I can just take 95 rook e8
yeah okay that's the way to go I didn't
plan this beforehand but it seems to it
seems to be working at least not losing
material on I mean it doesn't lose
material and the other the other one was
winning a pawn but it was just too ugly
so this is lucky but this was available
I didn't didn't see it before okay the
good thing is you know he probably needs
to take what else okay I just recap him
so we didn't try anything anything fancy
here um probably there wasn't anything
to try but you never know
okay so lucky hm winning winning this
tempo first should be should be okay
wait wait wait wait Queen h5m Queen age
v g6 Queen h5 hmm I didn't think about
that I should have taken the wish of the
night first tweenage v g6 I can try
Bishop f7 even the Queen eh v g6 Bishop
of 17 f7 Queen h7 check but this this is
probably nonsense right for white yeah
he puts the the Queen completely out of
play
okay so if the second time that I'm
lucky him twin edge v g6 bishop of 17 f7
Queen h7 check Bishop g7 and then if the
knight moves this rook h8 ripping the
Queen this is what I'm talking about so
he needs to meet the Queen to some
somewhere else okay can go to H fire but
it's it's probably pointless yeah I was
expecting that more but my idea was one
idea was that if I take now yeah that
probably should take
I have the possibility to play can play
rookie form not that it's clear that it
is anything great but maybe
yeah but why not why not why not
centralize this piece
it's not so clear where he would go now
they have this potential for further
temple gains for example if he goes
Queen g3 I could think about playing h5
attending rook g4 and it's a it's juicy
on g2 the possibility what he cannot
play at all the screen f3 okay so look
h4 is probably yeah nothing move not
really paying any any sort of her
dividends let's let's consider through
gauge for a queen g3 and h5 now I can
just play f3 so this is probably not so
great
hmm no no I mean I'm certainly all right
here but I don't I'm not sure how to how
to play this there's always this tension
against the b5 pawn
okay but how is he going to continue I
mean the next move is Bishop III
probably completing development the good
thing about my position is I'm really
nicely developed this is this is really
good I have the pieces active on f6 only
seven my bishops are great and c1 Bishop
is not doing much this is a position
which almost would be a worth upon but
I'm actually thinking about right now is
probably sounding completely wacky I'm
thinking about d5 it looks terrible I
know
killing the bishop that his bishop is is
even worse on b3 this is a classic setup
the dead bishop hmm yeah I wonder if
this maybe a maybe a good idea 35 and c6
Bishop c8 and then reroute the bishop
hmm this is an interesting choice
because my bishop is excellent as as is
I mean and playing d5 what yeah but I
can't play Bishop c8 c6 Bishop said it
is certainly a good position troop like
but is it is it the best system
the difficult thing so what else is
there somehow playing with the bishop on
g2 for example I dislike rook here I'm
really unsure okay let's do that at some
very debatable decision of course the
point is that the D and beef d5 pawn and
the b5 Paul basically prevent this
Bishop from ever getting into play again
he can never play c4 and TM me I can
play Bishop a2 b3 c for long term but
with the bishop on e6 this won't work
so this is basically a dead piece it's a
very common motif known as the yeah is
it no less to kappa blanka bishop
there's a classic game winter against
kappa blanka where winter allowed not
exactly this one structure but a similar
thing on the on the Kings side and he
had g3 Bishop that was out of play
and summed something similar out of the
format's game happened in the game short
against chrome Nick in the London chess
classics I think in 2000 and
Levin I think it was in 2011 among love
mistaken
10 or 11 I think 2011 this we're short
had the step bishop on b3 so the the the
difficult or the the the strange thing
here is in comparison to the other games
is that here I had a good position
anyway and I didn't really need to to do
that
wait what are you doing here the ship c8
I defy the singing okay I play I thought
first Bishop c8 would actually win
material already bishop CA detects the
Queen like like win g3 Bishop h4 Queen
f3 Bishop g4 and the Queen is trapped
this is actually nice but Bishop CAG can
go it can play Queen h5 attacking d5 so
let me let me do that this was planned
anyway and now I'm actually threatening
Bishop c8 with the Queen trap at least I
think that the Queen will be trapped we
can sometimes easily overlook it the
small detail and the Queen has some
square but I think Bishop c8 is is a
real threat now
at the point of this bad bishop is are
playing against it is that and how
exchanges are very much in my favor the
only thing that of course I shouldn't do
is if you place let's say Bishop D for
at some point I shouldn't exchange and
then our C takes d4 without winning a
pawn okay but when upon this is some
something else but I must make sure that
these pawns stay where they are and for
instance Bishop endgame only the two
bishops here we should be three against
b7 if you remove all other pieces would
be a very easy win because black plays
c5 c for bishops on a2 and it's
completely dead and they're playing with
an extra bishop here so on I only need
to only not easy but only if you need to
exchange pieces correctly to increase my
my advantage
this is why D 5 C 6 was an interesting
plan because it just sets up a structure
that it's inherently so favorable for
black that you have a very easy plan and
the plan is simply to to get into the
winning endgame in the other if you play
on if you play without that and play on
your activity you need to find a
concrete a concrete plan to to increase
your activity and maybe build up an
attack maybe this is better
but I mean mathematically better I mean
but it's it's it's divots more difficult
to play okay this is interesting the
ideas probably that he wants to allow
Queen takes a form so let's say Bishop
c8 Queen f3 Bishop g4 Queen takes you
for but I can take one too
yeah okay but this doesn't really help
him okay okay this doesn't really help
but but is there something else that I
can do I can rock edge force
it's a bit pointless now Bishop ca2 e6s
is certainly a good idea maybe Bishop c8
okay what his may be able to do is play
Bishop d4 which is of course a sermon
not so desirable
okay but this this first assist is okay
and maybe Bishop tune to e6 or Bishop to
d7 next okay now he's got this idea to
take and of course this I cannot cannot
allow also it would would immediately
activate activated position
okay so I thought I could just play
Queen d7 here maybe I'm wrong Queen e7 a
b5 this Bishop g4 and then it's it's
really working
okay let's do that Bishop g4 first is a
threat so you will not be able to take
on b5 I I expect H 4 H 3 here and then
maybe just Ruby 8 you know maybe you
played I can take a look it's Evan no
yeah okay they don't really have an
alternative yeah my piece coordination
is not perfect I mean okay the structure
has explained this it's nice but I don't
have an ideal piece set up you know okay
seven No yeah the rukon mmm maybe I
should have somehow not sure how somehow
should have gotten this look back yeah
this this is actually this is
interesting I thought I had thought
about this before if it takes Queen
takes this exchange operation is this is
this a problem for me I don't think so I
don't think so I still like the end game
against the the bishop so I don't mind
him to take on on the f6 and damage my
pawn structure
taking myself is out of the question
okay I just I need to connect pieces the
other this is not good the c8 and b8 so
Bishop f6 Queen Queen takes gf this is
okay I don't don't mind that not ideal
but I don't mind it
yeah I suspect that with precise player
widest probably selenium that he managed
Bishop differences is quite an
achievement and of course let's let's be
honest the port structure with the GG
porn it's not it's not ideal it's not
terrible but not ideal okay he could
have taken on e4 maybe wasn't okay let's
look at this later okay so now we we
approaching the endgame what is the main
thing here I need to get rooks off the
the bishop endgame would be would be
what I would I like to see a play rook
e8 to have rook e8
okay 70 is very active probably when
Rudy 4f4 and stuff now probably this is
enough to to keep it balanced oh wow
this I didn't consider
I mean it's giving the b2 pond it's
obviously aware of the the problems of
this the step bishop okay but not let's
not be too too too quickly
okay ready to take it is giving me be -
I mean this is this is at least Paul I'm
not sure that you needed to do that
really I mean I have I have plenty of
play against c2 as well
we need to also I'm not sure that is
that that this was the the best way to
defend okay so you create the threats
rupee three once in a while that sheep
tricky might help okay d4 d3 trying to
exploit the bishop yep
the hanging position of this bishop and
okay here's my extra pawn let's move it
also Bishop d6 as a possibility
yep rookie on e7 is there some direct
way to play
I don't should be six I don't like
hmm Bishop g6 and iam maybe d3 is still
a threat
okay
and I thought I could play maybe maybe I
should just go
Bishop you form
yeah the bishop is very nice to them
Brooke I have seven I take b3 and Bishop
f7 Idris go to h8 I just have gained a
great square on e form
one minute 31 this is not good so let's
try to be a bit quicker but he's trying
to make good moves as well investing a
bit of time
yeah didn't have much more time to think
about that do you three
mmm III we can take III ya don't like
that move
I didn't didn't see anything great check
you know
check
this is some it's just Rakim that's
let's threaten a mate you can get my
king up here but I don't think I made it
I thought I can escape we can check me
here and check gg5 and so on but I can
run all the way to h4 and then I'm I'm
using the king to meet him so on
okay this will be a matter of quick
quick plane okay be equalized timewise
check
I can run all the way to edge form check
and then drive McInnis is even helping
him not taking because you gave form you
should check finish for then look at
shreya the keenest King is helping okay
so probably how can I will probably win
this on time but let's still try to play
good news okay take this rooks III okay
this is hanging time warning you never
have Bishop g5 check check
no this is Luke him hmm
check check
white for fits on time Wow yeah this was
a game well an increment which would
have been awesome to to just continue
it's somewhat logically this game very a
very intense fight okay here I'm
probably winning but I I didn't play
this one I allowed them too much counter
plane this is still probably alright
yeah and here I wasn't sure I mean the
computer just wants to play there should
be six here which is the most obvious
move but I didn't want to do that here
because this looks this looks ugly but
of course I have this idea which I
didn't really appreciate to fight for
the seventh rank yeah it's still not
clear to me if I'm winning here or how
much might want to just worth okay I had
to add this idea which isn't too bad I
don't know anything so yeah this was
already a bad move but I didn't really
find something now compounds to go ahead
sector pawn yes a substantial counter
play check
yeah here this is really shaky for white
for black oh sorry
check oh he has a winner he has to win
here which I didn't see the computer of
course he's lying cently Wow great move
rook g2 rook g2 why is this winning okay
if I take it bishop f7 Wow and g5 made I
cannot prevent g5 made yeah this is
amazing
of course I mean a human player how
would you find this in 20 seconds yeah
cool absolutely great I cannot I have no
no forget this I can check to do this
and then I have no move to prevent g5
checkmate so this is how he could win I
mean it looks a bit precarious position
died I was I didn't see that
yes can you play this and rook cheated
look g2 here draws funny enough I don't
really understand it if I take oh this
is winning hmm okay yeah but this is
really computer chess probably the F
pawn in connection with the king
position yeah this this is very
difficult
yeah and this is also winning for whitey
okay we both had absolutely no time on
the clock check check
kingi one is the one I don't really know
why and instead check this F fire
forward Bishop d3 yeah yeah this is what
computers are good at chess okay yeah
yes sir
getting the F pawn to go yeah it was
very very messy at the end very
interesting was was this point where he
played c4 this was really an interesting
decision the thing is that he was
obviously aware of the implications of
the bishop what I'd like to do quickly
to to illustrate my point here let's
just imagine for a moment that this
would happen
check then here black is in excellent
shape I can show you what to what I'm
thinking what I'm talking about the
computer completely here doesn't
understand the position and gives it as
equal which is quite quite funny so
let's just imagine this kind of position
wide what cannot do anything anyway so
here this is happening at the end and
this is a dead piece while my bishop is
playing and I'm I will at the end will
break through him and as an additional
weakness so when this is what he was
afraid of that at the end he will get
this this terrible ending this is very
similar to the kaepa blood to the short
kramnik game in this game in the short
comic game Kramnik didn't have the
double points I think I'm pretty sure
and he wouldn't he won this really
easily yeah this is what White was
afraid of to get into this in the long
run I would just put up some sample
mousses wasn't necessarily an absolute
best play phone
but why does very very much struggling
it's probably lost and this is why I'm
he didn't want to allow that so the
question is but if this is the case then
rookie follows already yeah I should
have played then d5 now would have been
interesting and the rook is somewhat
misplaced but I only got the idea one
moves later
the computer also plays c5 intending c4
which isn't bad at all
also very good news and here the
question is yes c5 is strong
I didn't again the computer points out
c5 I didn't consider that which is a
shame but because it's just a great move
c5 c4 hmm yeah this was bad I should
have considered this much better than d5
what d5 is is interesting from a
strategic point of view just like I
explained um I should have so seen c5
the idea is quite similar but but bit
different
computer points out before he a
strongman okay
we should be five as a computer
suggestion yeah yeah interesting this
yeah I should have considered that works
okay you're not a comp so he can cannot
see all the news but yeah interesting
I didn't mind this because I wanted to
get nearer to the endgame this is
probably still still a bit a bit too
quick I mean the the issue is it really
gets ugly when the rooks off but he's
got Luke a7 and King F 2 to protect
those squares and he's got active rooks
so it's not so easy for me to to
exchange them program alright a very
interesting game hope you enjoyed it